c'est un déluge judiciaire sans
précédent qui menace le gouvernement
au moins 71 plaintes ont été déposées
devant la cour de justice de la
république dans le cadre de la crise du
coronavirus par ministre n'échappe à la
colère des citoyens qui portent plainte
en groupe
seules avec ou sans avocat au palmarès
de ceux qui sont pointés du doigt
edouard philippe le premier ministre
mais aussi olivier verront ministre de
la santé et sa prédécesseure agnès buzyn
on retrouve également christophe
castaner ministre de l'intérieur nicole
belloubet garde des sceaux ou encore
muriel pénicaud ministre du travail
ils sont accusés de mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui non-assistance à personne
en danger et homicide involontaire les
plaignants des médecins détenus élus ou
candidats aux élections municipales et
dénonce des mesures tardif pour endiguer
la pandémie de kovy 19 et la majeure
partie des plaintes s'appuie sur
l'article 223 7 du code pénal quiconque
s'abstient volontairement de prendre ou
de provoquer les mesures permettant sans
risque pour lui ou pour les tiers de
combattre un sinistre de nature à créer
un danger pour la sécurité des personnes
est puni de deux ans d'emprisonnement et
de 30000 euros d'amande et ce qui a mis
le feu aux poudres c'est cette
déclaration d' agnès buzyn le 17 mars
dernier dans les colonnes du monde
je savais que la vague du tsunami était
devant nous le 30 janvier j'ai averti
edouard philippe que les élections ne
pourraient sans doute pas se tenir
on aurait dû tout arrêter c'était une
mascarade une mascarade qu'elle a
pourtant omis sur le moment de révéler
aux français fin janvier agnès buzyn
persiste et signe
le risque d'importation du virus en
france est très faible pratiquement nul
cette volte-face de l'ancien ministre de
la santé tend à prouver que l'absence de
mesures de lutte contre l'épidémie était
délibéré d'où cette pluie de plainte
aujourd'hui contre le gouvernement
contre edouard philippe et agnès buzyn
on retrouve celle des médecins qui
dénonce un mensonge d'état sur la
question des mains
sks et plus généralement sur la gestion
de la crise pour nous protéger au
cabinet nous avons dû nous fournir chez
des carrossiers c'est tout de même
incroyable d'en arriver là des stocks
existent pourquoi les distributions ne
se font-elles qu'au compte gouttes
nous réclamons un véritable audit sur
les stocks de masques
il fallait agir plus vite et s'inspirer
de l'expérience de la chine et de la
corée du sud
réaliser des tests à grande échelle et
procédé un isolement ciblés comme dans
ces deux pays
on voit bien que c'est ce qui s'est
révélé le plus efficace contre
christophe castaner candidats et
militants les républicains montent au
créneau après avoir été contaminée lors
du premier tour des élections
municipales
deux jours seulement avant la mise en
place du confinement
même son de cloche dans les prisons où
des dizaines de détenus ont porté
plainte contre nicole belloubet aucune
mesure sanitaire n'a été mise en place à
l'exception la suspension des parloirs
famille pour protéger tant de personnel
pénitentiaire que les personnes détenues
aucun masques et gants de protection
aucun gel hydro alcoolique il a été
distribué les distance d'un mètre
préconisé dans le cadre de la campagne
de prévention ne peuvent être effective
en raison de la surpopulation carcérale
protégé par son immunité pendant toute
la durée de son mandat
emmanuel macron et pourtant visé par
quatre plaintes les procédures
judiciaires devraient durer plusieurs
années
au delà d'une condamnation ces plaintes
représente surtout un enjeu politique
le sénat va d'ailleurs ouvrir une
commission denquête le gouvernement aura
la lourde tâche de prouver qu'il n'est
ni responsable ni coupable